bien que la trajectoire et l'intensité
10,5 soit encore incertaine la saison
cyclonique est bel et bien lancée et si
on n'est pas totalement démunis il y a
toujours une petite chose qui manque à
la maison pour se sentir prêt si vous
avez la charge sur votre voiture pour la
recharger dans la voiture aussi
nous sommes sans arrêt tu vois
[Musique]
le vendanges et d'autre les faucons de
précaution des landes 1 de l'essence de
tout l'attirail faut pas négliger
avec ce qui fait passer à côté d'un
zelda côté je pense qu'il faut pas me
faire attention à ce que ce que j'avais
besoin de bidons pour aussi jamie à une
coupure d'eau là je vais acheter
de quoi mais cleri en cas de coupure
d'électricité aussi ai-je appris voit
aussi du scotch pour renforts aussi les
baies vitrées
vous n'aviez pas sur la maison encore
non parce que je viens d'acquérir un
bien donc je sais une première c'était
chez les parents il y avait tout c'est
plus simple de près on se dote de tout
ce qu'il faut faire et à mesure des
choses lumière et eau
pas plus donc je suis venu occuper un
peu de lumière
l'état d'esprit est ce que vous abordez
cette possible tempête sereinement
maintenant on sait pas trop à quoi
s'attendre donc on commande ils n'ont
qu'à prendre rang avant de louer donc ça
va on est seul vrai on attend que ça
passe
depuis deux jours ce magasin vont
certains produits par palettes entières
ce qui part très peu pendant l'année se
retrouve vite
des valises et on a eu une première
vague sur sur tout ce qui est groupes
électrogènes
ensuite on a eu les bâches et depuis
lundi on a faim depuis ce matin on a une
grosse vague sur tout ce qui est
éclairage tout ce qui est pile tout ce
qui est éclairage d'appoint
on sent que les gens ont besoin de se
rassurer savoir qu'ils ont des clercs à
chez eux qui vont pouvoir tenir quelques
jours ce client prend le premier groupe
électrogène venu or un peu plus loin le
choix est bien plus vaste et ceux qui ne
sont pas encore équipés ne connaissent
pas vraiment le produit pas vraiment
général justement
ils viennent pour questionner en
fonction de leurs attentes par rapport à
l'appareillage qu'ils ont brice harpin
connaissent qu'un jour là pour
conseiller et sur l'utilisation ce que
vous avez l'impression que les gens vont
savoir s'en servir
pas forcément justement non mais pour la
mise en oeuvre c'est pas évident a
toujours s'il joue pas le bon sens
s'impose lors des achats de dernière
minute et les articles en tête de
gondole ne sont pas forcément ni les
moins chers ni les plus adaptés aux
besoins de chacun